Johnny manzugai searches for sea turtle
nests in the middle of the night
he says the tall waves of La Union in
Northern Philippines crashing into the
cold silent Darkness make it ideal for
hatching
Johnny's family has been hunting for
Generations
[Music]
my grandfather used to hunt for sea
turtle eggs on the beach he would track
steps made by mother sit Turtles I used
to follow him around so I learned
those eggs would be eaten or sold but
Johnny no longer hunts for Commerce or
consumption
he's now one of the many poachers turned
sea turtle patrollers in his town they
work with a local conservation group
Coastal underwater Resource Management
actions or Karma
they turn over eggs which average 100 in
each nest for which they can make around
forty dollars previously when we first
got into the communities we had to earn
their trust and it took some years to
grow with them nowadays when we have
releases you'll see the local the elders
come out and call the children and
explain to them how the sea turtles are
our partners
sea turtle hatchlings are also helping
fuel the local tourism industry Sunset
releases into the ocean have become
quite the spectacle
well the program here in La Union has
been successful poaching of sea turtles
and their eggs continues in other parts
of the country in January eight men were
arrested for illegal possession of 15
dead sea turtles
the sea turtle was a victim of poaching
as well and is being rehabilitated by
Karma
the organization's founder Carlos Tamayo
says only a fraction of hatchlings make
it alive when left on their own
these sea turtle eggs were found by a
fisherman but they'd been crushed
between waves and a sea wall so that's
also one of the reasons why we
transferred them into the Hatchery you
know as much this weekend we'd like to
find the nest and put them in land
Higher Ground you know away from the
tides since 2009 chroma has released
more than 33 000 hatchlings into the
ocean the goal is a million by 2030.
Carlos hopes to replicate what they do
in the rest of the Philippines home to
five of the world's seven endangered sea
turtle species
partner below Al Jazeera La Union
Northern Philippines